at the lobbies at the las vegas natural
history museum where you can learn all
about these prehistoric creatures with
their paleontology week jc is live with
more hey what's behind you be careful
well hey rocky and kendall first off
here's the real deal this is dr roland
the real deal the real paleontologist
thank you for having us what is behind
this they're asking what is this guy
right here this guy is named dinonicus
it was a feathered dinosaur lived in the
cretaceous period a vicious little
attacker you wouldn't want to meet him
in a dark alley no and is this is this
the scale yeah it's the full scale and
and we put feathers on it because we now
have solid evidence that many many
species of dinosaurs had feathers we
know they were quite closely related to
birds and so this is a full-scale
reconstruction of dynamics he's a scary
deal let's let's walk along here because
you have so much going on it is
paleontology week here at the museum
what is that that's right paleontology
week is a is a week where we celebrate
the fossil record especially the
dinosaurs because of the movie coming
out this weekend uh but paleontology is
basically paleontology week every week
at the las vegas natural history museum
but this is a week where we're specially
celebrating the the dinosaurs and the
other fossils that everybody loves so
much now behind you this guy is like the
main event the t-rex he's the main event
is this one i loved it it's so
interactive here at museum you push the
buttons they come to life is he to scale
yeah he is a full-scale t uh t-rex
fossil that's right with the team with
the defense why were their arms yeah you
know that's a big mystery that we we
have lots of fun trying to try no we
don't understand it and there's plenty
of room for new paleontologists some of
the kids out there to to when they
become paleontologists they can figure
out why that is we don't know why it has
such little arms there's still there's
still mysteries to solve absolutely lots
of mysteries lots of new fossils to find
in and nevada and las vegas area is
especially rich in fossils let's move
down here so the triceratops was it
triceratops here on the west coast where
was he yes triceratops was definitely
here in the west coast during the
cretaceous period north america was
divided into two big islands and
triceratops was one of the last
dinosaurs to live and especially on the
western island where where nevada is so
it was all over the place it was one of
the last surviving dinosaurs this is
fascinating i mean you go see jurassic
world this weekend or come down here and
experience the real dinosaurs and this
guy here is new to your existence
dilophosaurus we're very proud of this
exhibit it's a new exhibit made
specifically for our museum and it shows
dilophosaurus this
carnivorous dinosaur that lived in the
jurassic period and it's set in a scene
similar to red rock canyon
a national conservation area there's
some some fossil footprints yeah let's
get a shot of these footprints because
you discovered these
footprints that are modeled after a site
in valley of fire state park that i
described and these are not footprints
of the dinosaur of course there are
fossil footprints of little
proto-mammals that this guy hunted so
these are the prey and he's the predator
doc you are a fascinating man i can
spend all day with you we have more
coming up here in las vegas now but i
know you've seen the jurassic movies who
would who would doc be in the movie who
would his character be anyone know who
did his character be didn't we figure it
out
you'd be alan grant i would be i would i
would be chris pratt that's how it would
work out chris brown
all right that's the best
what dinosaur